[Music]
in Parma wins news yeah submitted by
where's Burton geo they just had a baby
wait oh they come here with the Bible
yeah they leave the kid at home and just
come here yeah for you they're not gonna
raise their kids the way they were
raised yeah a millionaire family who
kept 18 homeless men as slaves will be
jailed for a total of 80 years
why get the [ __ ] out of here got real
pleased to say 80 sleep did I say 80
sleep 18 18 oh wow they got it twisted
because he just did some flat fan
attribute he just felt these people out
I gave them a place to live and they're
getting in trouble for it what
constitutes a slave yeah someone who is
there against their will also they
didn't want to be there indentured
servitude isn't that kidnapping then it
sounds like a 95 to me yeah what's the
difference but you guys say it in a
costly and poetry way oh right yeah it's
like five is a matter of five or is it
what is a nine to five if you don't feel
alive well I hate beat poetry hate it
Nikki took me one time and I was trying
there and I was I used to do this thing
when I was in fifth grade where I had
the most boring teacher in the world and
and while she was giving a lesson I
purposely went like this I did that [ __ ]
during this [ __ ] beat poetry like I
was in a movie what if he's like man
he's really filling this because he's
really like he's cool Yeah right
jerk anyway this family they have kept
18 homeless men as slaves when one of
them at least for 26 years Jesus so they
raised someone that long yeah he lovely
he loved his slaves what the whole
family
full plan of people that had a plan of
slaveholding have you ever heard people
say that where it's like you know the
slavery thing it was wrong but they were
treated pretty good how would they even
know isn't that long long time ago no
it's like that happy slaves book oh yeah
so uh they forced these men to live in
these tiny little trailer homes and live
in really horrible conditions we're late
well they're saying that everything had
urine on it was it was it like that
before or did they treat it like that is
the question I want to know too and he
has a TV that's a big that's a big
screen yes when they were grabbing a
homeless men who had alcohol addiction
problems or they had mental problems so
they would kind of trick these men into
saying like oh you know come live with
us we'll give you food shelter alcohol
it sounds too good to be true well you
could work for food yeah and then you
know you'll get paid and so initially
when these men were going they would get
paid but very little and then over time
they would just stop getting money and
then whoever was an alcoholic they would
just give them a little bit of alcohol
here in there to keep feeding that
addiction so in an a forced them to live
in these tiny little trailers they would
get beat man he said that they made him
dig his own grave and they were saying
that if he wouldn't sign this contract
that pretty much gave them permission or
whatever to have him as a slave that if
he's legally binding contract yeah he
wouldn't sign that contract then they
were like that's where you're gonna end
up which is the grave that he had just a
Bestine and then they would hit these
men with like shovels brakes one man was
even he got two teeth knocked out by
getting hit but with us
he's a senator then like they would be
made to clean up their own blood from
the feeding so it's kind of [ __ ] up
it's a bit much there yeah here so this
is this man and his twin brother what
colony twins they are the two most kopo
kopo kopo nailing it cold so they were
the ones I got the most and so this is
John wait is he a victim or Z no no this
is the family members perpetrators oh
there were 11 people that been arrested
and so there's 10 men one woman and
they've accumulated 80 years of them
being the question what kind of slave
work are they doing do they own a
plantation what are going ten men one
women right so there's 11 people behind
this yeah tiny guys [ __ ] your sister
yes so there's almost like a servant for
every single person you're pretty much
but they they would make these men lay
pavement in their property area so I
guess they have like this area where
they would have a lot of trailer homes
and they would have their own home and
they would have these men work on their
home and like force them to why don't
the 18 guys just rise up against a tent
because they were they were being beaten
like drugged out and stuff probably
their little weak there like the people
we see on Skid Row probably you know
poor guys yeah so this this family made
more than 1.5 million pounds and then
they spent all that money on a notice -
okay yeah very lavish lifestyle
including homes holidays and flashy car
1.5 million split among 11 people is not
much how did they get the money that's
what I wanted to know - yeah like what
did they make them give locks on the
trailers I don't see yeah what are they
doing like picking British start
strawberries or something we're like
they clean the guys pool yeah for 80
years same work cuz back in the 26 years
well 26 years
yeah but like if you have slaves back in
the day how they did it was those slaves
were making stuff that they made money
off of so what the [ __ ] were these guys
yeah they were working in the farms
picking cotton or doing something that
made the plantation rig there was a
financial reason for it
yeah maybe they're not telling us yeah I
couldn't find what they made I'm doing
that because it costs money to feed 18
people and just keep them there just
even if they're not paying rent or
anything yeah I'm not sure because the
only thing that they would mention is
that they were forced to work tar
macking and paving drives from the clams
bases and like their properties and
stuff but they have a guy and it's
called a clan they that's what they call
me here with the C construction company
and those are their day laborers or
something yeah they don't really go into
detail them even help oh that makes
sense because the in the article it says
they had their different properties
right yeah so contractors bases plan
bases that that's crazy
who would what kind of a sick mind you
have to be to come up with such a great
genius plan it's a genius plan is
foolproof yeah it's really airtight if
you think about it like cuz who's gonna
believe the homeless people I'm a slave
it's like yeah it's pretty and who's
gonna miss homeless homeless people like
they don't dirty down-and-out didn't
have family well the thing is too that
they were mentioning is that the family
so some of these homeless men they would
get benefits from the government and
this family would just keep it oh so
then that might be what added up the
government's never like me and a lot of
people live at this [ __ ] address yeah
yeah it might be like hey they're
banding together and they're turning the
life around look this is great oh right
they found a trailer park to be together
it's like we went by the home it's
really beautiful they're doing really
well there had to be inspections yeah it
sucks cuz I think they make fun of
homeless people a lot but then they are
easily victimized like they're not
missing any family no one's looking for
them there's no accountability for like
anything if they go missing or what and
they can be used for a lot of things
they're also saying that if some of
these men finally would build up the
courage to run away they would have the
whole family hunt them down and bring
them back
and scary that's [ __ ] up yeah that's
really thought that so I'll go through
the the rest of the family members so
this is John gel for 15 years
well how did they get caught that's what
I wanted to know - oh my god one got
loose yeah only 15 years I was reading
there's more slavery now than there was
like in the 1800s yeah no way yeah
majority of them are sex slaves though
yeah well that in the like in Saudi
Arabia and like in Africa like there's
tons and tons of slavery still more
compared to win in the 1800 in the
colonial times I mean maybe because we
have more people now just is it like per
capita I mean slavery guys like from the
beginning of time I mean how was there
more now oh I just said 1800 like yeah
probably like in ancient Egypt dude
probably way more than John got 15 years
Patrick is doing brother look at him
he's like yeah you got me he also got 15
years he was the best buying [ __ ] and
then the rest of the family members I
don't know what the relation is she
looks like she brews up some concoctions
in her [ __ ] basement with a big pot
while she goes yeah she got seven years
you got a mustache dude she should go to
jail for that mustache guys I didn't
know well he makes a lot of people yeah
how's thinking that he's like a pizza
dough throw I didn't know slavery is
against the law he's me it's like the
guy just told him right now slavery is
against a lot bla are there in London
right through there bread the real are
you joking you've got a big inmate right
this one oh man look at these people
don't have [ __ ] shampoo yes you got
all their money on slaves
cranly he was already in prison he got
another six years Wow that kid how did
they do that he look like a fight he is
his arms are crossed wow this guy do you
wanted to take his mugshot with style he
got two years that's it what did he did
did he not do maybe she was just
freeloading off of us bended for
conspiracy to defraud can converting
criminal property yeah converting
crimped he was a real estate agent that
was working he got them the trailer
who's the supervisor this guy got six
years why do they all look like they
work at fast-food restaurants yeah well
they're the same family so they all look
the same
oh and mug shots are tough we know this
yeah they're tough to to look glamorous
during there's a kung fu master what he
possibly could be Asian I know
he teaches white food don't touch me I
sue you got one year and in jail and
twelve I'm sorry two years suspension
this dude he was jailed for six years in
nine months they all look very sad yeah
well they're all in trouble I think if
you're 70 years old in 2017 with the
fauxhawk you should probably go to jail
11 years trying to be young again this
one got six years he's alluring he
that's his alluring look why dad they
look so weird it's like let's do it
again I'll give me something sexy this
is you Lander look oh that's so sad
homeless guys we finally got through
justice and it sucks a lot of them like
one of them apparently is now a broken
shell of a man
they were broken but now they're shot
the good news is now they're out of
those chairs and they're back on the
streets and I think that's real nice
you ought to me it's like goddamn what
do you think about it laughing it how
much that sucks nowadays not not at him
yeah that's not like the cops go hey
we've saved you you're free now get the
[ __ ] out of the trailer nowhere to go
delivering no it's like can you at least
give me some money so I can get back on
my feet like I'm nowhere to go after
this they probably started GoFundMe for
all these people no not these guys so
there's nowhere an article about how
they got caught or anything like that
cuz that's a mystery yeah I don't know
oh man there's a rash when I was able to
find I couldn't find that answer I hope
you guys enjoyed this video for more
please subscribe to our Channel and you
can check out the last video right here
[Music]
[Music]